cada una de sus manos tiene cinco huesos
llamados metacarpos entre la muñeca y
los dedos
en la base del pulgar el primer
metacarpiano forma una articulación con
un hueso de la muñeca denominado
trapecio
el tejido liso llamado cartílago cubre
los extremos de los huesos en la
articulación
el cartílago amortigua la articulación
también permite que los huesos se muevan
fácilmente cuando rota gira
O agarra cosas con El pulgar
la osteoartritis del pulgar también
conocida como artritis basal del pulgar
es una afección en la que el cartílago
de esta articulación se rompe y se
desgasta
sin cartílago los huesos se rozan lo que
puede dañar la articulación
con el tiempo pueden formarse
crecimientos óseos llamados espolones
óseos dentro de la articulación y
alrededor de esta
puede tener un mayor riesgo de contraer
osteoartritis del pulgar sí es mujer ha
tenido una lesión previa en la
articulación como una fractura o tiene
un ligamento inestable y laxo en la
articulación
los síntomas comunes de la osteoartritis
del pulgar incluyen protuberancias óseas
en la articulación Dolor e hinchazón en
las articulaciones
y pérdida de la movilidad articular y de
la fuerza de presión
si tiene preguntas sobre la
osteoartritis del pulgar hable con su
médico